und damit jo Leute was geht herzlich
willkommen zum neuen Video ich befinde
mich hier gerade wieder in Bangkok am
Flughafen wie man hier sehen kann es ist
gerade wirklich Rush Hour also so voll
habe ich sie noch nie gesehen ich war
jetzt etwas über zwei Wochen in Thailand
und jetzt geht's endlich weiter ich
freue mich auch schon wirklich sehr und
zwar fliegen wir wenn ihr die letzten
Videos verfolgt hab nach Tokyo erstes
Mal in meinem Leben nach Japan und das
coole ist wir fliegen mit AirAsia und
natürlich testen wir heute da die
Business Class das Interessante ist das
ist ein Billigflug also ein billig
Flieger billig Fluggesellschaft deswegen
bin ich echt mal gespannt wie es wird
schon wieder mein Gott ey dann rein ins
Getümmel und ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
bei dem Video wird sicher cool ich bin
echt gespannt auf Japan aber ich glaube
da werden einige coole Videos dann
stehen wir haben jetzt gerade 20:30 Uhr
wir fliegen erst um 23:50 Uhr dann durch
die Nacht quasi also nicht lange
schnacken los geht's das ist hening den
kennt ihr sicherlich noch wie hat dir
Thailand gefallen war super aber
anstrengend ja es war echt anstrengend
also wobei das wird in toky
wahrscheinlich nicht besser junge was
ist hier los alter das ist ja so voll
Puuh so wo ist unser Gate oder unser
Terminal ach so übrigens weil ich es
gerade hier sehe wir fliegen jetzt hin
mit einer billigfuggesellschaft das wird
so ja ich denke trotzdem ganz cool und
hier könnt ihr aber sehen Swiss First
Class damit geht's zurück ey das wird
ganz ganz wild der Flug war auch
ziemlich teuer aber da könnt ihr euch
auf ein geiles Video freuen Alter ey ich
fühle mich wirklich wie in der
Hochsaison in Deutschland wenn alle nach
Malle wollen oder so das ist die
Schlange international departchers
Terminal 2 sind wir auf jeden Fall ah
hier steht's jetzt Asia
s111a s111a also als ich das letzte Mal
von hier geflogen bin da war da niemand
da habe ich da das Video angefangen und
jetzt ist da einfach eine ich verstehe
das nicht na ja ab durch Security Check
wir standen gerade fast ein Stund an
diesem Security Ding da na ja auf jeden
Fall müssen wir jetzt noch mal 15
Minuten lschen na ja da sind no ein paar
Lounges Teil können wir nehmen Qatar
heute leider nicht miracle auch ja komm
schnell wir haben nämlich nur noch eine
Stunde Zeit dann ist auch schon
Boarding
[Musik]
Shuttlebus
okay das sieht schon verrückt aus Leute
ganz lustig wenn man Mönch ist darf man
hier sitzen das sind priority
[Musik]
seats also das ist mal ein flughafenz
oder ganz schön schnell okay wir sind
mittlerweile angekommen am richtigen
Terminal oder was auch immer das hier
ist okay und normalerweise wenn man
bsiness class fliegt ist ja auch immer
eine Lounge am jeweiligen Startflughafen
mit inklusive heute bei AirAsia habe ich
das nicht ich könnte mir irgendwie noch
so ein Red Carpet Service dazu buchen
das hätte noch mal mehr gekostet da
dachte ich mir ne brauche ich ja eh
nicht ich kann jetzt aber mit meinem
Kollegen hier wegen priority Pass halt
in die Lounge gehen und hinter mir ist
auch jetzt die letzte Lounge die kommt
wir müssen da hoch hallo wir hab nicht
mehr viel Zeit deswegen let's go so
miracle CIP Lounge nicht VIP sondern CIP
und ich hoffe da kommen wir jetzt auch
rein na ja schauen wir mal ja sieht doch
ganz nett aus
okay thank you ist ja nichts los hier
sollen wir uns dainsetzen also von einer
absolut überfüllten eingangssal am
Flughafen zu einer Lounge wahrscheinlich
findet hier einfach niemand hin sieht
wirklich aus wie ausgestorben also fast
zumindest so schauen wir uns mal das
Angebot hier
an baked chicken vegetables oh ich bin
echt positiv überrascht das ist ganz gut
Kürbissuppe hier haben wir sogar auch
noch Frühstück dabei Curry also für eine
priority Pass Lounge ist die wirklich
echt super kann man nichts sagen so
kleine Stärkung für zwischendurch gleich
auf dem Flug gibt's ja auch noch was ich
bin echt mal gespannt wie das wird ich
habe für den Flug 800 € bezahlt wir
fliegen auch nur 6 Stunden guten Appetit
aber ich glaube später das wird die
schlechteste Business Class in der ich
jemals war darauf erstmal eine pumpkin
zu ist eine Kartoffelsuppe die haben
vergessen die Schilter zuauschen oder ja
ja ey krass das hatte ich noch nie
priority Pass Launch mit showauer hallo
sorry e krass so sieht hier die Dusche
aus wow ich bin echt begeistert also
damit hätte ich hier wirklich nicht
gerechnet vor allem ist ist auch alles
blözeblank geil Leute noch ein kleiner
nachag das Terminal was ihr hinter mir
seht das ist nicht das schlechteste hier
das das ist das neueste ich habe es
irgendwie total vercheckt aber i hat im
September letzten Jahres dieses Sat 1
nennt sich das Terminal aufgemacht und
deswegen freue ich mich gerade dass wir
von hier aus fliegen weil sonst hätte
ich das gar nicht gesehen ich habe mir
schon gewünscht dass wir hier ankommen
auf Hinflug sind wir nicht deswegen
schaut euch doch mal dieses schöne
Terminal an was ein Terminal
oder was ein Ding hier mein Gott ich
glaube wir bleiben hier wir können da
Flieger ach so ja da unten ist schon
unser Geld okay dann waren wir mal ab
ins Boarding so hening fliegt economy
dann B später du kannst wieder das Essen
Filmen falls was
KR
hey thank you das wird ein bisschen
stressig wir landen um 8 Uhr in toky und
müssen dann eine Stunde noch Zug fahren
Hotel haben auch noch nicht okay
CIA es ist aber immer gemein der muss
ich da jetzt hinquetschen ich habe
wenigstens ein bisschen Platz Leute ich
bin gespannt wir fliegen hier Airbus
A300 keine Ahnung
hallo yes thank
[Musik]
youy okay ich muss mal ein bisschen
nachsynchronisieren ich bin auf jeden
Fall in einem Airbus A330 geflogen und
der erste Eindruck war wie ihr sehen
könnt nicht gut Privatsphäre hat man
hier eigentlich gar nicht ich habe auch
nicht viel erwartet muss ich sagen aber
das hat mich dann schon ein bisschen
schockiert weil man daravon nicht
vergessen ich habe für 6 Stunden Flug
800 € bezahlt wir sind dann auf jeden
Fall gestartet ich habe keinen Plan was
sie da vorne verstaut haben es klang auf
jeden Fall echt
[Musik]
komisch und wie ihr wahrscheinlich schon
gesehen habt ich hatte nicht mal einen
Bildschirm man muss sagen dass ist aber
glaube ich bei billig Airlines normal
die Langstrecke fliegen wobei ich bis
vor dem Flug nicht mehr wusste dass es
sowas überhaupt gibt also ich kenne
zumindest kein dieser Namen von den
Langstrecken billig Fliegern aber es
gibt ein paar ist aber absolut Müll ich
hätte für den gleichen Preis mit Thai
airace fliegen können da hätte ich einen
viel besseren Komfort gehabt mit
Bildschirm essen oder für 100 50 € mehr
die japanische Fluggesellschaft al
Nippon Airways also wenn Ihr Business
Class und billig Flieger hört und dann
auch noch für diesen Preis meidet das es
gab auf jeden Fall eine Decke da habe
ich mich sehr drüber gefreut und ich
wurde gefragt ob ich mein Essen nach dem
Start oder vor der Landung haben möchte
und ich habe mich für nach dem Start
entschieden wer ist bitte um 6:30 Uhr
Curry mit Reis na ja gut neben mir war
dieses Touchpad damit konnte ich mein
Sitz verstellen und in die Liegeposition
bewegen was ich sehr lustig fand als ich
mir die Karte anschauen wollte habe ich
eher so ein Merch Shop von Air Asia
gefunden keine Ahnung wer sich da
wirklich so eine Mütze bestellt na ja
dann kam das vegetarische Curry ich habe
es probiert und ja es war echt ohne
Übertreibung das schlechteste
Flugzeugessen das ich in meinem ganzen
Leben gegessen habe und auch noch lustig
ein Wasser ist umsonst wenn man aber
lieber eine Cola Fanta Sprite oder so
haben will muss man dafür bezahlen ich
habe nicht mehr viel aufgenommen wollte
bei der wenig Privatsphäre auch kein
stören neben mir saßen ganz viele
Japaner und ich kenne die Kultur nicht
habe da mal respekt bin dann noch kurz
aufs Klo gegangen so kurz bevor ich
schlaf gehe noch kurz einmal die
Toilette ja sieht aus wie in jedem
normalen kurzstreckenflieger ich habe a
800 € bezahlt für diesen 6 Stunden Flug
und ich muss sagen also wirklich echt
meine Meinung nach viel zu viel das
einzige was gut ist dass ich da so
halbwegs schräg liegen kann es ist kein
Bett so sondern eher so eine Rampe aber
alles andere kannst du komplett
vergessen aber okay ich habe mich auch
irgendwo natürlich drauf eingestellt ne
jetzt Augen zumachchen und ab nach Japan
dann ging es schon ins Bett liegen war
okay ich konnte wenigstens meine Beine
ausstrecken gemütlich geht anders gute
Nacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so von
32° auf
4 das war echt kein entspannter Flug e
Leute also ich will mich gar nicht
beschweren vom Komfort her war es ja
echt okay ich konnte wenigstens meine
Beine ausrecken aber also das Produkt
als Business Class zu verkaufen ich weiß
ja nicht das ist ungefähr so als hätte
Ryan eine Business Class also eigentlich
macht eine Business Class in diesem Ding
gar keinen Sinn das war ohne Scheiß der
turbulenteste Flug in dem ich in meinem
ganzen Leben drin war es ging die ganze
Zeit nur rauf und runter ey man konnte
echt keine Sekunde die Augen zu machen
das war wirklich scheiße weil jetzt bin
ich total müde und habe eigentlich kaum
geschlafen und die Business Class hat
sich so noch viel weniger gelohnt na ja
was geht was geht also was ich mich
gerade frage kann es irgendwie sein dass
es vorne im Flugzeug immer mehr ruckelt
als z.B ganz hinten weil er sagt bei ihm
hat's gar nicht geruckelt voll komisch
ich fand so extrem ich bin jetzt echt
wirklich gespannt wie hier alles so
aussieht und wie das auf einen so
wirklich selber wirkt weißt du weil
Japan ey dass ich mal irgendwann in
Japan bin das ist auch geil kommst am
Flughafen an und hast direkt erstmal
paar Pokémons wie hei er noch mal
glomanda shigi miotu Bisasam Pikachu
Garados Garados war das genau ich bin
auch echt super gespannt auf das
japanesische Volk wie die so drauf sind
ich glaube die können nicht so so gut
englisch habe ich mich ein bisschen im
vorhinin drüber informiert aber wir
schauen einfach mal das soll h ja alles
super organisiert und geordnet ablaufen
hoffen wir mal dass wir hier jetzt nicht
noch wie in Thailand eineinhalb Stunden
anstehen um unseren Pass zu zeigen so
wir sind drin Japan Alter heiß das halt
oh m da war Thailand natürlich schon
besser ne sieht ein bisschen aus auf
jeden Fall wie halt eigentlich so wie
Österreich V vom Klima her in den Bergen
direkt hier völlig die abgespacen
Automaten schaut mal cool gib glaub ich
ist das meinst das ist Kaffee ja ne ja
steht da ja Koffe ich probiere das
direkt
[Musik]
mal also ich finde landschaftlich sieht
es so aus wie in Bayern wenn es im
Herbst schon richtig kalt ist oder
gerade Winter wird und es trotzdem kalt
[Musik]
ist g los sind auf jeden Fall jetzt
mitten zentral hier in tok ich bin mal
gespannt wie gleich der erste Eindruck
ist wenn man hier so rauskommt und ich
freue mich auch sehr aufs Hotel weil ich
bin total
ko willkommen in Toko junge dass ich
hier mal bin e ohne Scheiß ich dachte
ich komme nie in meinem Leben hin oder
also ich hatte jetzt nie so wirklich den
Grund aber auch schon geil B mal
gespannt wie hier die nächsten Tage
werden so Taxi
Taxi
so endlich im Zimmer ey bin ich kaputt
das war wirklich anstrengend irgendwie
diese Reise ich bin eigentlich hart im
nemen aber das hat mich irgendwie
gekillt okay wir haben uns jetzt erstmal
noch ein bisschen ausgeruht und laufen
jetzt aber direkt erstmal Richtung so
Kaufhaus das nennt sich jetzt habe ich
den Namen schon wieder vergessen
bisschen New York Feeling hier aber
schauen wir mal wie das gleich so
aussieht okay Jacke habe ich gekauft ich
glaube das ist diese berühmte Straße
hier die man kennt oder wo man wo alle
über die Kreuzung latschen es ist so
cool so weiter
geht's hier sind einfach so viele
Menschen es hört gar nicht auf und es
werden immer
mehr so jetzt gehen hier 5000 Menschen
gleichzeitig die Kreuzung rüber das ist
übrigens die Kreuzung die ich eben
meinte aber ja okay jetzt könen wir
wieder
gehen Kreuzung okay mittlerweile wieder
im Hotel ich muss sagen wenn man hier
rausguckt auf jeden Fall eine super
coole Aussicht Tokyo ist echt eine sehr
impressionsreiche und überfüllte Stadt
also manchmal habe ich mich gefragt wie
viele Leute hier unterwegs sind das ist
einfach unfassbar also egal wo Du bist
es ist einfach voll Leute laufen dir
entgegen hinter dir vor dir links rechts
das ist wie so ein riesen ameisenrennen
einfach man wird von überall mit
irgendwelchen Lichtern geflasht und weiß
eigentlich gar nicht wo jetzt genau was
abgeht na ja wir war ein bisschen
shoppen jetzt wird sich erstmal
ausgeruht die erste Nacht hier
geschlafen ich bin auf jeden Fall
richtig gespannt auf die nächsten Tage
und ja ich freue mich auch noch ein
kurzes Fazit zu dem Business Class Flug
falls man das also ich trau mich
eigentlich gar nicht das so zu nennen
das war wirklich also wenn man bedenkt
ich habe dafür fast 800 € bezahlt das
ist wie ich schon gesagt habe Ryan Air
Business Class also von dem Standard her
auch das Essen das war eine eine
absolute Zumutung aber es war eben auch
nur ein billig Flieger na ja abonniert
ser sehr den Kanal freut duch auf die
Videos aus Japan hier wird einiges
kommen und ich Fall jetzt erstmal
todmüde ins Bett und wünsche euch eine
gute Nacht